We have talked before about how when you have
a situation where a particular population
is vulnerable very quickly, grifters come
out of the woodwork and they try to take advantage
of vulnerable people and really sick and disgusting
ways.
So one example of that, I told you last week
this some Christian, a televangelist who was
previously in prison for fraud.
Jim Baker, he and a natural path were selling
something called Silver Solution, which they
said could kill or neutralize or destroy or
deactivate the virus.
That was a scam.
The New York attorney general sent a cease
and desist letter yesterday.
I told you about televangelist Kenneth Copeland,
a guy worth about $760 million.
He has been healing people of the virus through
his television during a special report about
Corona virus.
And you probably aren't going to be shocked
to hear that conspiracy theorist Alex Jones.
Is hawking a toothpaste that kills the virus
as well as his food storage stuff.
This is Alex Jones who has been kicked off
YouTube, Facebook, Spotify.
I guess he's just publishing content on his
Web site at this point.
Here's Alex Jones explaining this amazing
toothpaste 8 7 7 7 8 9 2 5 3.
Not on the show Tuesday.
Little transgression.
I'm not going to belabor this.
I'm just going to tell you that for just your
daily life and your garbage and your teeth,
for regular viruses and bacteria, the patented
nano silver we have, the Pentagon has come
out and documented and homeland security and
said this stuff kills the whole SA's Corona
family.
At point blank range.
Well, of course it does.
It kills every virus, but it's ticking.
They found that this was just 13 years ago.
And the Pentagon uses the product we have
and the product we have in private label is
about to be in Wal-Mart coming up that they've
just ordered a massive crap ton of that, not
the one they have.
That's even better one that we have.
I'm just saying, we're always cutting edge
thanks to God.
I just I just go with the research.
Go with the spirit.
We always have it.
The nano silver toothpaste in the Schriever
Blue with the tea tree and the.
And that's Super Blue's amazing.
And we have the whitening toothpaste that
has the nano silver and a lot more as well.
Those are both excellent and for short our
commercial discount, despite all the hell
breaking loose.
We have storable food in stock, but we have
to package it and it's six to eight weeks
behind shipping it out to other people a lot.
Telia, big old Pinocchio noses, we're not.
That's what's going on.
You want trouble so you won't get delivered.
This thing of it is that bad takes in about.
Twelve weeks in the US, the model show.
So you'll get your food imports come and it's
high quality, it's very low price.
They haven't raised prices yet, but I'm told
it's next week for store dot com and bodies
also determine formula is back in stock as
well.
Yeah.
So the New York state attorney general has
also issued a cease and desist order to Alex
Jones over the bogus toothpaste.
When people are vulnerable, they will be preyed
upon.
The entire concept of multi-level marketing
scams, by the way, it's often preying on vulnerable
people.
I know there are exceptions, but for the most
part, if you have a steady and reliable job
and a good work like life balance, you were
not going to fall for the idea of making a
hundred bucks selling who knows what.
By recruiting other people and selling products
that people don't really want because you
are not in a situation where that is appealing
to you.
You are sort of satisfied with your steady
job and the balance.
You're not looking to get a second job and
start selling whatever these multi-level marketing
scams and network marketing scams.
They also prey disproportionately on vulnerable
people and sometimes just on board people
or gullible people in the same way.
You have people worried about the virus.
Maybe people who are more vulnerable based
on their age may be more vulnerable or even
maybe people who don't believe in like normal
medicine.
And so they are going to fall for stuff like
Silver Solution or toothpastes.
They are going to be more likely to fall for
this stuff.
And, you know, just think about it at its
face.
The virus is a respiratory illness, which
means it gets into the lungs.
That's how it infects you if you breathe in
the virus.
It goes past your mouth and your teeth, which
is what you're dealing with with toothpaste.
It gets into your throat.
It gets into your lungs.
What's brushing your teeth going to do even
if this garbage product did kill the virus
in your mouth, hypothetically?
How are you going to deal with the fact that
it's in the lungs?
Even if you swallow the toothpaste, unless
you choke, it's not going into your lungs
unless it goes down the wrong pipe.
And also saying it kills the holes, holes.
SA's Corona family is hilarious because the
common cold is sometimes a corona virus.
Common colds is usually an upper respiratory
virus.
Sometimes it's rhinovirus.
Sometimes it's PPIC coronavirus.
And sometimes the common cold is a coronavirus
strain.
He's suggesting that the toothpaste kills
the common cold, for which there is no known
cure at all, not even even in a broader sense
than coronavirus specifically really dangerous.
I feel terribly for people falling for it.
It's horrible that our judicial system, including
attorneys general in multiple states, are
having to, at this time of crisis, deal with
sending cease and desist orders to people
like Alex Jones and Jim Baker, although it's
good that they're doing it, to be very clear.
It's right that they're doing it.
It's just disgusting that this is what they're
having to put time into.
Horrible, horrible, horrible stuff.